let me go let me go get him
i'm sorry guys i don't like it i don't
like it
no no no
no i'm really embarrassed the way he's
talking to debbie and reyna
you don't tell my friends to shush
and stop
um are you okay i'm okay i'm sorry i'm
smoking my jesus though okay
you could smoke it's okay go go go go go
science pokemon they they mean well
they're not judging you too cool lucy
come
on come on wait you want to be alone
okay cool all right
all right
i feel like i can't say anything right
now i know when he acts like that just
to like
walk away let him calm down let him cool
off
but he needs to chill out because
we have less than 90 days to get married
and right now i have cause for concern
he doesn't want me outside with him
right now wants to have a cigarette and
calm down i guess
i'm gonna be the next to walk out of
here he feels like he's being personally
attacked and i get it
i think he's not understanding where
we're coming from he's not used to women
talking to him like that in a strong way
i don't like it
he has to understand where he is you got
to help him with that
yeah can i go out there not judging him
at all
go ahead
listen since he's been here i've had to
question him about the pictures
and everything and this is the same
reaction i've been getting
[Music]